the Audi front you w220 as an automotive
milestone it was one of the first German
made vehicles built according to a
modern platform strategy
now it's let's fight classic car expert
Christophe Bauer says the Audi front is
the result of a fusion between German
manufacturers Porsche dkw wanderer and
Audi in 1932 the know-how for the
front-wheel drive came from the auto
unions dkw division the engine from
wanderer and the sedans wonderful body
was produced by Horsch christophe says
today it's standard practice but back
then car makers sharing technical
components was truly visionary between
1933 and 1938 4,400 LD fronts were
produced first with the cubic capacity
of 2 litres and 40 horsepower later with
2.5 liters and 50 horsepower the car
came in various styles as a four-door
sedan a sports sedan a convertible and a
roadster back then front-wheel drive was
still in its infancy
first up says with front-wheel drive
when you steer and accelerate at the
same time you feel the surging power at
the wheel just a little in modern cars
but here he says it's like the steering
wheels being yanked out of your hands
due to the high steering force and large
turning circle howdy front drivers can
break into a sweat in city traffic or on
winding country roads
but as early as the 1930s the stylish
six-cylinder OD found more suitable
terrain first up says the first German
Autobahn was open to the public in 1932
the a 555 between Cologne and Bonn it
was perfect for the Audi front with its
top speed of 100 kilometres an hour and
even the chassis was state-of-the-art
independent suspension in the front a
pendulum axis in the back
combined with the vehicle's relatively
low center of gravity for the time it
makes for relaxed driving even today in
spandex so relax and enjoy the sights of
Tuscany
the high season San Gimignano is abuzz
with tourists life in the medieval
Tuscan town has now slowed to a
leisurely pace
Christophe says the car feels very
luxurious apart from the gearshift this
number one symbolized outies high
standard since 1923 with the front
howdy entered the upper-middle-class
market the cars main selling point was
its modern technology front wheel drive
a box frame and a straight-6 engine with
an impressive 40 horsepower crystal says
the Audi front is also a feast for the
eyes with its shapely lines this
roadsters body was made by Glaser a
coach builder from Dresden Boston Jose
Glaser in Destin only a minority of Audi
front models received a closed car body
in the horse plant in neighboring Sekou
most LD front customers opted for the
open top versions produced by
convertible specialist Glaser in Dresden
they came with a choice of four or two
side windows
the dashboard gearshift is a typical
feature of early front wheel drives
Christophe Power says the letters u W in
the cars name stood for Olga Caravan
dava the back-to-front wanderer it
referred to the fact that the car
featured a wanderer engine that had been
turned around to drive wheels which were
now ahead of the engine unfortunately
the gearshift and transmission
diminished the driving pleasure
Christophe says that in 1933 the press
hailed the Audi fronts gearshift is one
of the most precise and smooth in a
front-wheel drive but he says that's not
true from today's perspective it rattles
and shudders especially in the first and
second gears the fourth and fifth aren't
bad provided you can find them it's not
so easy as this old gear shift has metre
long rods going into the gearbox in
front so it's not very precise and you
have to be careful with the reverse
there's no lock for it and changing into
the wrong gear can be costly only the
third and fourth gears are synchronized
but then again what trendsetter is
perfect christophe says Audion parked on
a new era with the audi front to this
day front-wheel drive is still one of
the car makers trademarks so the front
is always a hit at marketing events
Bauer says it was the first
upper-middle-class European car to
feature a 6-cylinder engine and front
wheel drive so definitely a milestone in
automobile history the Audi front was a
trailblazer in many ways way back in the
1930s the iconic car already lived up to
the car makers later slogan Washburn
wash technique or advancement through
technology
you